check your Six Gang the state trashy
tour is rolling along we're coming to a
city near you little ayg with the crowd
plus a nice stand-up comedy show grab
the squad and come out and see us yeah
next stop is Tampa Florida second show
added low ticket alert there get them
baby then we're going to Dania Beach
Florida Raleigh North Carolina
Louisville Kentucky Cleveland Ohio then
Round And Out Columbus Ohio we're out of
more cities get those Dickies welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that if
they go to be classy enter just a big
old piece of trash I'm your host Dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're out back here at tuddy's in the
new edition baby the rise of Toady
continues oh yeah just bought a
pickleball team
gonna have them throwing some games this
summer I respect respect my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the CEO of Ru garbage he's an
international businessman and he's my
best pal in the whole wide world just
got back from doing a little Consulting
for the Saudis so the kid's doing all
right talk about oil money give it up
for KJ Kevin James Ryan what's up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
as you know those numbers are
cooking and obviously the greatest
website of all time www.patreon.com
it's a party over there yeah it's having
a nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works the ones Works to
twos works the threes and the fours now
crosses them T's and dots them eyes now
you can get a little sneak peek at him
ladies on the old Toby cam there he is
T-Bone mcgruffins Toby McMullen
everybody hey what up dude what up Tebow
I'm stoked we got the LA homie and came
in smelling like the stickiest of the
icky
holy [__] gang the long hair ain't lying
we couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest back with us again today of course
he is the host of the Honeydew podcast
and he has a brand new special out right
now on his YouTube page Lefty son do me
a favor give it up for Ryan sickler
everybody there he is all right guys
there he is just listen first of all
thank you for having me of course thank
you for coming back I appreciate the
first one it was pandemic
[Laughter]
do we
[__] off
yo it's two bucks for the Fiji Water by
the way
I'll send you an invoice at the end of
the month no problem
you went to the bathroom twice too by
the way yeah well I'll tell you what I'm
gonna be honest with you about that
bathroom for a guy that's got a [__]
up back that's a hell of a step
you should have some emergency tape on
the floor and give somebody a heads up
watch your step you're gonna get a
lawsuit I made two of my policy my
premium was paid when you went back in
there someone's suing you guys two
months into this [__] you're gonna be
right back on a couch yeah it's gonna be
me I'll tell you that
oh
that's trash you see yourself I'm sure
my own insurance company [__]
I'm making the payment this guy's an
idiot he's negligent
ah buddy congrats on the special man
it's cooking so much it's doing good I'm
very uh I'm very happy it looks
beautiful I never think anything's gonna
do well thank you I look this is
something I did uh I directed it I
produced it and all that [__] myself I
found the the diet shout out to the is
this me right here the dynasty
typewriter yeah
and his crew and my buddy Sam Vaughn
helped me pull it off my producer
Kirsten you know how it is there's so
many [__] people that help you do
this stuff then you're putting out a
free special and it's like
you know Ari told me too you gotta and
then you gotta go travel yeah you know
you're going to Austin to do something
you come to New York you don't you don't
just make it you don't knock them all
out and one fell swoops you gotta come a
couple times and it's important to do
this part of it now so working baby I
appreciate you guys having me here are
you kidding me congrats on all your
[__] success thank you [__] love
appreciate it we're so excited to have
you here uh you know doing it over the
zoom you know we were doing what we had
to do but all we talked about since you
were on that first time zone man can't
wait to get them in you were one of the
guys together when we made the show we
were like sickler yeah I feel like I'm a
cousin yeah it's Bill yo it's Bill free
this guy's a real ham and eggs
exactly it's family he came in right
away someone's gonna get sued in there
[Applause]
it is I think it is that Mid-Atlantic
you know Philly Baltimore it's the it's
that blue collar
it's you know angry angry but comedy is
very uh valued it was like you know it's
like who can you fight and and what kind
of jokes you can that's right 100 100
yeah all right let's get into a little
because it's been a while uh-huh yeah I
don't if I repeat anything I'm sorry
I talked about last time but I'm I'm
ready a million years ago it was it was
quite a bit ago we want to just do a
little recap find out a little more
um something I thought of uh any uh like
baseball picks when you were a kid you
played you played little league right
you never end up on a Wheaties box or
anything
um the fake stuff like you know the fake
Sports Illustrated did you get did your
parents now see look I'm 50. so back
then man you you just got down on one
knee and put your arm on
that's the classic pose that's all you
do I did the classic Little League post
it wasn't until like my younger
brother's about four years younger than
us that's when they started getting the
All-Stars
that's not me man we were just we were
disposed and if somebody had a dog we
put them in there in a team picture
yeah so you remember drinking out of
those huge yellow coolers oh yeah the
yellow Joe the hepatitis jugs yeah I
remember those yeah I remember those
that's what we all used to drink out
everybody's got herpes everyone's
scooping their dirty ass
it was always a couple of grass
clippings
always bro
yeah give it a little flavor it was all
right I remember to leaning over and
just smelling that and you can just
smell the chlorine and the [__] pine
tar in there
I'll tell you one of my um the worst
Little League pictures I've ever [__]
had
this is just humiliating because I have
a twin brother where we look nothing
like fraternal twins and we were both
very good I was just I'm the smallest my
mom's six foot I'm the shortest person
in my [__] family okay so this one
season they didn't want both of us on
the All-Star team so they just chose him
but you know we're Twins and my dad's
like you're [__] coming you gotta
come and they were like how about you be
the bat boy and I was like how about
y'all go [__] yourself I'm better than
any one of these [__] out on
the field I ain't pulling it back I
respect that [__] that but it's a
picture and I have it somewhere it's
it's like a purple maroon it was Taylor
Taylorsville Winfield athletic is like
t-w-l-a-a All-Stars you know but I'm
talking listen
also
we didn't have the Orioles uniforms and
the white like they have now we have we
were the Braves but it was a t-shirt
that had iron on letters that said
braids it wasn't much you were the
purple team it wasn't much different
than this to be honest there was no
embroidery on this no no there was no
number on name on the back it was just
like baby said like John's Towing on the
back listen Supply was it that's what I
was gonna say who was the sponsor it was
100 stem stems Hardware yes Supply
Company shout out stems for all your
local hardware needs but we had um I
didn't make the team but then my dad's
like come on I want to take a picture
I'm like I'm not taking a picture he's
like you're gonna put this shirt on
and rep your brother and then I had
those it was it was white shorts with
blue piping around them oh yeah what I
mean oh I know what you're talking about
instead of nut Huggers
t-shirt on I've Got My Socks all the way
up and I'm just mad dog I just [__]
every one of these kids out here and
it's humility I hate that picture are
you old enough to remember when when uh
guys were wearing half shirts yeah they
were half shirt generation I wore one
you wore a half shirt I didn't not in
high school or anything I wore it I have
a picture of me too in a Seattle
Seahawks half shirt
so I had I started liking different
teams and I found Seattle out there with
Steve Largent and Dave Craig and I got a
I got a white mesh Seattle Seahawks you
know XXL or whatever across the middle
athletic department oh bro you just made
me think of this here you go [__]
yeah
well before you're right here all right
Ocean City Maryland
it's where trash blows too
it's not even wearing a word it collects
down there the birthplace of Gonorrhea
shout out to secrets
secrets everybody's just peeing and
drinking yeah you can go out in the
water just pissing
but I wouldn't and I'm looking back at
this now like I can't believe my parents
let us do this I would never let my kids
but every year it was a big deal there
were two shirts we wanted to get there
was always uh there was a place called
BB bombers it was a surf store and they
had a buckwheat shirt okay and every
year it was some different buckwheat
from The Little Rascals uh shirt they
would design every year so that was a
big deal to get it and come back to
school because if you had that shirt
you're reflex oh [__] he's wearing three
days in a row they went all the way to
Ocean City for that they took the bus
and then the other one was we could go
in and we could get any shirt we wanted
with a fresh iron on oh yeah back when
they would take the whole thing and
can't tell me nothing with a fresh iron
I had that smell like
some felons doing it for you for sure
and it's a wall of you know concert
music they still have all that a van
with a rainbow going over here they
gonna suck itself or something
[Laughter]
man I wish I get that Mom no you're not
getting that
I remember being naive I'm like suck
what Mom shut up
but I end up getting no [__] lie a
Moosehead Beer [__] logo on a black
half shirt I remember I remember it
vividly now you asked me that and I'm
well I'm 10.
half shirt on my child I'm like what
like if I had if my daughter was walking
around right now with a Budweiser
t-shirt on I would say who the [__] put
that on I didn't do that get that [__]
off you're eight
but yeah it was all about that iron on
those t-shirts back in the day for some
reason like a t-shirt like the like the
buckwheat one that you're talking about
are like um uh I grew up in PA so like
big in Lacrosse and if you got a hold of
a Garden City Long Island lacrosse
t-shirt had Bart Simpson on the back
maybe your brother or an older cousin
had it they wore it for like three
Summers it was worn in perfectly dude
man yeah so sweet those t-shirts they
just got first they'd maybe have a
little rip or whatever but they still
look cool yeah in the 90s I remember
wanting uh
my mom's like you're not wearing it to
school
I had one one time
I used to wear shirts all the time I
went on stage early on in my career I
wore a [__] New York t-shirt I almost
got beat up at the [__] Hollywood
Bowl For That t-shirt too but it was an
Orioles shirt with orange it was an
oriole Yankee sure sure uh but also
um I wore this one I went to yo y'all
ever go to Kings Dominion
the amusement park in Richmond Virginia
yeah yeah it's a it's paramounts
paramounts Kings Dominion we just drove
by it I know yeah we were just we just
did Richmond it used to be Hannah
Barbera Barbara so we used to park you'd
Park in like the [__] hair bear a lot
or Yogi Berry or whatever where you
parked you know that kind of that's all
right but I I remember one time being in
high school and um
I have no parents at this point I'm 17
and I go to Kings Dominion I'm a punk
I've got this [__] shirt on it's got
two dogs having doggy style sex on it I
don't remember what it said
but I remember trying to get on the
Rebel Yell roller coaster and they
[__] told me I had to turn it inside
out or I had to leave the park and I
fought it but then I but I really wanted
to ride the grizzly and the white we
hadn't hit the White Water Canyon or
whatever you remember that remember that
yeah this dude is all time bro I love
them I love them
Eiffel Tower over there man [__] I have
a couple of them you know they do the
Rebel Yell backwards now that was my
favorite all these other roller coasters
are coming in and making the old school
one look bad and they were like well you
know how can we Jazz this thing up and
they were like we're gonna run this
[__] backwards
it was a whole new ride like oh [__] oh
[__] okay I love it I love this t-shirt
but I do love posters
that's when you're torn I think they
were just trying to get me to buy a
King's Dominion shirt really take it off
but back then I looked good I would have
walked around I would have walked around
with it tied around my neck you know
yeah I didn't have titties though
I don't think I never not had titties
four-year-old I was a pudgy little kid
would you rock to cut off jean shorts
never really really no I had I've tried
them one time but I was like yeah even
even John Cena doesn't make it look cool
for me
to it's not a good look I had buddies
that had it and I was like nah John Cena
only look good in jean shorts and a
braided belt it was all about that
braided belt you had to have the it was
an extra long part of it
twist it down in the middle yeah our
styles were weird we argyle socks were
hot for a minute honey loafers were hot
for five minutes
um
or something we used to they used to
call I remember my brother and sister
used to do it all yeah Timberlands were
big uh too but not yeah the old not the
the nicer Timberlands the like the
darker loafer yeah maroon
okay you guys do you remember are you
old enough to remember jams of course
shorts jams shorts okay that caused I
was in like uh seventh and eighth the
riot Bluebell Pennsylvania people were
nuts for him had to close them all down
they went nuts what are they that just
like they were short life's a beach hats
do you remember those yeah man all right
if you can't hang with the big dogs get
off the porch That's when op was big Ops
all right yeah I never wore those shorts
either they were always too short yeah
dude they were so hot for a second in
the 80s so again being trashed my
mother's like it's that whole [__] we
got McDonald's at home I'm like no we
[__] don't and my mom makes us jams
bro out of what just fast just went to
Jo-Ann Fabric shout out to Joanna every
drug dealer got their dime bags
I never walked in I walked in I'm like
yeah my mom did a lot of buttons at the
house
what the joy of fabrics just bought some
[__] flower [__] patterns and I
mean the thinnest [__] [__] it ripped
right away you know it was embarrassing
and it doesn't say jams on it so that
was the whole thing and I went to school
too before Target existed and had Tony
Hawk's clothes and [__] so if you went
to Kmart and you got their brand of
shoes which I've had they're called look
them up they're called McGregor's oh I
know them
bro you would get your ass beat if you
brought across the McGregor's at the
wrong part I had a pair of McGregor
cleats yeah yeah the spikes would pop
out like bad teeth
[Laughter]
and then I remember this pair of shoes
two were called I think they were called
Olympia or Olympian and they were
similar to that but they had this fold
over tongue and that photo that tongue
was fast yeah it was dope
[Laughter]
is Rich English guy [__] to me
you remember Wildcats I do remember
Wildcats are kangaroos are you too young
for kangaroos Zips a little pocket on
the side yeah put your lunch money
that's where those little punks will put
their little Loose Change lunch money in
there for sure kangaroos you know who
was a big supporter kangaroos Walter
Payton yeah Dr Peyton used to have ruse
on his [__] yeah he was a kangaroos guy
um Zips I remember Zips when they would
do the Z in the dirt with the shoes Zips
it could make a z in the dirt yeah all
right man I have not remembered Wildcats
until Wildcats
at the end I'm gonna have to go to
therapy or hit a Kmart see if we can get
your hands on Realize where I've come
from go cop some fresh gear after this I
need a half shirt and a pair of jams
I'm not that [__] my mom made we're
getting the [__] out of here
that's good stuff oh okay all right have
you ever washed shoes in a washing
machine or dishwasher yeah that's a bad
look yeah not a dishwasher I I've also
never done a ball uh cap in a dishwasher
I've seen that before I used to sell the
I don't know if they've never washed the
bulkhead they sell the the crate you put
it in yeah no never works it always
[__] up the hat and [__] up the
shoes man I was uh here's what I used so
yeah we used to wash our shoes
but then and also used to say wash by
the way his family says that a little
bit and it wasn't until I moved to
California like it wasn't until my 30s
uh someone said to me what are you
saying over there how are you saying it
wrong I go what I'm putting it in the
washer yeah I'm gonna wash my clothes
and he's like spell wash and I go
w-a-s-h she goes where's the r and I
went oh my God where is the heart ain't
no RNA and it made me it made me I
worked on that one we used to say
Hamburg instead of hamburger really
we're gonna have some hamburgers how
about vehicle yeah
what were the tags on a vehicle I got
too close to the car one time my mom was
pulling in the driveway and she screamed
up the side window get away from this
vehicle yeah
my stepdad used to say karaoke for
karaoke
we used to also uh it took me a while to
learn how to properly say uh because we
used to say ambulance
not an ambulance
Chris cotton God Rest his soul how about
an umbrella he used to hit umbrella yeah
umbrella I'm an umbrella say it again
umbrella that's umbrella yes
how about how about the color orange how
do you say that orange my daughter's
Army she's like it's orange Dad I'm like
it's orange it's
a-r-n-g-e all right hang right there
that's arm yeah and there's an oriole
shirt that's out right now that says
orange and black and it's spelled like
that and I sent it to her I go there you
go I might buy it just to wear it around
the house
um on this same thing how do you
pronounce the product that Crayola makes
band I'm gonna tell you something right
now because it ain't right if one of
y'all [__] calls it a crayon
I'm gonna [__] start swinging in here
because it's a crayon
I I say Crown Crown how the [__] do you
get there crayons better than Crown oh
my dad was dumb there's three different
pronunciations and that same thing at
this one table pack of crayons baby
we're all crazy we're from like 200
miles
I don't care what the I don't care what
they're called but if you got that 64
pack with the sharpener yeah
right away okay let's talk about Lucy
Lucy Lucy Lucy yeah let's talk about
Lucy baber level up but Lucy's nicotine
Breakers it's a nicotine patch with a
surprise inside Lucy Breakers have tiny
capsules that burst open and at least
volumes of flavor oh yeah delicious
flavors like mint mango Berry and my
personal favorite espresso don't be
getting your nicotine fixed at some gas
station do yourself a favor get over
there to Lucy get you fixed anytime
anywhere 50 off Breakers check out
subscribe and save option yeah gang so
give yourself a little surprise when
life feels overwhelming you deserve it
it's easy peasy at Bob one in you get
your little kick in the keister as I
call it you know what I mean visit
lucy.co that's lucy.co and use promo
code garbage you get 20 off your first
order shipping is always free that's
Lucy l-u-c-y dot c-o promo code garbage
to receive 20 off and always free
shipping here comes the fine print guys
Lucy products are only for adults of
legal age and every order is age
verified this product contains nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical this
episode is brought to you by better help
oh yeah get into the house to see a
therapist can be some sometimes uh
challenge it ain't always easy to get up
and get moving and let me tell you
something from experience finding the
right therapist is a little bit of a
pain in the ass you end up sitting there
you're just talking to somebody you
don't even know what they're listening
or not it's only taking you eight years
yeah but do yourself a favor get over to
better help take it up you can do it
from the Privacy your own home and the
good thing is they might have
Specialists that aren't in your area
yeah gang uh I highly recommend it's uh
talk therapy is is a Monumental tool
that can help you at any point in your
life whether you just need a little
sounding board and a little kick in the
butt whatever it is uh talk therapy can
help and better help can help you with
that you can do that from the comfort of
your home or bed uh and no one judges
you it's convenient flexible and suited
for your schedule fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and get on your way
to start living a better life if you
need a different therapist you can
switch it anytime discover your
potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com garbage to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
help.com garbage do you old enough to
remember NFL pencils
yeah sweet I was all right I I hated
Trapper Keepers Trapper key I hate it
we had aluminum lunch boxes like you
could [__] somebody up like a minor
yeah
it's like a goddamn tin knocker
around the NFL metal lunchbox with the
uh and that was before it was like uh
all the teams were there I had a Fall
Guy one a Dukes of Hazard one and you
just opened that [__]
nice thermos
grape juice in there you were all right
Kool-Aid yeah I was I caught the tail
end of metal but like my older cousins
has when we had the metal ones there
would be like there'd be like pencils
and [__] in there yeah like a storage
but let me tell you something the Fall
Guy that's something I always that would
be such a Fall Guy the Fall Guy was a TV
show uh with Lee Majors who was the Six
Million Dollar Man he played a stunt man
in Hollywood that also worked as a
private investigator and such an 80s
show that's crazy
it was him his goofy buddy named Howie
that's right and an absolute [__]
dime piece that ran by the name of
Heather Thomas Amen brother and Marky
post Marky post from Nightcore that's
right God she just passed away she did
yeah she passed uh she was the [__]
IMDb over here she was the lady that
like uh organized all the uh the jobs
for him she was there what Bosley yeah
they had sexual tension dude it was such
a good show and every show in the 80s
had a sick vehicle a team van Knight
Rider and [__] Lee Majors used to
ride around in this Bronco that was
[__] stacked out you remember that
well I think it was uh I'm gonna there's
one thing I'm gonna correct right it was
look this I think it was a GMC pickup
okay yeah I think it was something
pretty sure it's two-tone Brown fat
tires with the lights on top and he sang
oh yeah that thing's mean no that was
always jumping um
okay I was I just looked for a t-shirt
for for it the other day because Heather
Thomas all right
man you're you're not lying about a
dying piece she was so [__] hot and I
would go into Spencer remember his store
shorts are in the mall and if you go to
the back I was there a couple weeks ago
you go to the back she's all right and
there's this iconic one of right there
of her pink bikini and I would just go
back into Spencer and just just drool
over that [__] poster I'm like I
ain't buying this but in the in the
intro to the show she would pop through
a cowboy door just in like in a tiny
bikini it's [__] like seven o'clock
on a Thursday night I gotta sell to
Goods you know what I mean bro let me
tell you something this is how this is
you want to talk about trash and how far
back I go
I used to set I learned how to set a VCR
to record because I used to jerk off the
Knots Landing
that dealt the Burke they did for me
wait Designing Women what year seven I
used to jerk off
okay
Knott's Landing Notch Lane back in the
day of my day and I'm like Middle School
this is after I figured out masturbation
I first learned how to jerk off before I
figured how to program a VCR not go in
order
but not not uh excuse me Knott's Landing
was uh back in the day it was big for
like uh evening soaps so you had to die
in the street sure
there were evening soaps and and somehow
I caught wind of Knots Landing and Donna
Mills was on there and uh Nicollet
Sheridan when she was probably in her
20s is on there like okay there are so
many Joan Van Ark there were so many of
these beautiful women there was a
brunette I forget and man I used to
record that and that [__] was on like
nine or ten maybe yeah so I'm supposed
to be going to bed so I would set the
VCR and I'd peek out to make sure those
two red lights were on I'm like all
right we got some churches
around I'd put that in there just watch
Donna Mills and [__] drive that little
topless Mercedes I'm like yeah you go
Donna Mills
some Hospital scene you're pulling it
that's what I was early jerk stuff go to
fisting.com
my homepage
people don't young people it's my search
engine Dallas was a huge oh he shot Jr
as a whole thing huge damn I missed
massive I feel like I'm still with my
grandparents oh we're only 10 years
[Music]
I told you we were driving through
Dallas I was like that building's around
here somewhere
it was like a week ago not where JFK got
shot but where J.R worked God damn it
goddamn oil tycoon we're doing a Dallas
tour down here what Book Depository what
are you talking about man we're here to
see who shot J.R Matt Jr used to get
laid in that bar right there let's pull
some trim out of there
um in the last 365 days have you ran
over a squirrel or hit a deer
you know what no because I live in LA if
I if I still lived in Maryland man hell
yeah I'm sure I would have clipping
something I did one time run over Square
on my bike and it made me wreck and it
[__] me up because the squirrel got
confused I was hauling ass down the hill
and it did one of these numbers and I
went right and it went right and I went
left and it went left and it froze and I
ran it over and I crashed and I was like
ah it [__] it [__] me up that was a
squirrel I just ran away I have no idea
that [__] they're like
crackheads dude you all ever um try to
catch any wild animals catch them not
kill them just catch them no not really
I don't think so we had a
unintentionally we had skunks in our
house uh one summer we're paying ran out
of a victim
we had skunks One Summer and my dad
hired this bozo of an exterminator to
come he set like six traps in our front
yard put like different kinds of peanut
butter and all this come out in the
morning you're in it
got the fat one again
you're hanging upside down from the
upside down your foot's in here foots in
a rope we came out in the morning there
was a possumen one a squirrel in the
other a fox and one cycle God this I
swear to God it was every other kind of
animals skunks are just peeking out like
you dumb mothers laughing at the fox
the kids are allergic to peanut butter
the kid's got the peanut I can't touch
this stuff can't even be around it we uh
We've we used to um so we used to sit my
grandmother's row home in Baltimore and
uh
my brothers and I used to shed a little
tiny narrow backyard and she would
always throw stale bread out in the back
and like 30 Birds would come in and grab
some we were one day we're like we're
gonna [__] let's catch a bird you're
not catching a bird and we old school
Bugs Bunny took a cardboard box and we
took two old school clothes pins wooden
ones and just propped that box up and
tied a [__] string to it right up the
in her dining room window me and my two
brothers would sit there and watch a
Stakeout for you right now and we're
just pulling it and trying to pull it
and catch these birds and my grandmother
would sit and talk to her one or she had
a bunch of sisters but she talked to my
Aunt Helen all the time and she'd sit in
a rocking chair she's like this is the
quietest they've ever been I love it
they think they're going to catch a bird
and this one [__] Crow got too far
under and we caught that [__] we
caught it seven years of bad luck it
might be and then we took it we put it
in we had a big dog kennel like thing in
the back okay for a dog we used to have
but we hadn't for like 15. I didn't want
to ask but yeah I knew it wasn't up the
code I want to get rid of the cattle
just in case you know
so we put it in there just to watch it
you know and check it out and it's
[__] blackbirds in there and then we
let it go and my grandma was like oh my
God
I said we got one and then we started
getting good at it we caught a [__]
blue jay whoa prettiest goddamn bird
I've ever seen up close we caught a
goddamn blue those are Slippery and then
and I this is when I learned that
rabbits kind of scream I didn't know
this but a baby bunny just shot across
and we were like oh and we pulled it and
it fell it's a light carbo it's nothing
it hit it like halfway on its back and
sort of Trapped it for a second that
[__] started going
oh
hold ass yeah it's brutal we got good at
that [__] we had a bad experience we my
buddy hit my cousin had a beat got a BB
gun and you know we were sixth seventh
grade wanting to be tough guys we went
out there was a bunny there was a rabbit
in the backyard and I took a shot at it
and I caught it in the back and this
thing started screaming man screaming
and then we had to go over and [__]
stop it from screaming do what we had to
do dude we went from badass to the three
of us him me and my brother are both
ball and crying
and plus we didn't do the execution well
I went up first missed caught him in
like the ear and then my cousin
using hell but dude then we then we took
it we buried it in front of the shed and
put a little cross in there and said a
prayer and dude if every time I don't go
over there I don't look out in that and
buy that [__] still there and think
about it yeah no no animal dug it up no
nothing's gonna come get you one day
yeah she's coming yeah
the [__] out of me pet cemetery ruined
me oh for about 10 years I know that at
seven years old never felt worse
somebody right after we had to put Rusty
down yes we had uh we had Daisy 880 BB
gun so it was pellet mbb that was the
hybrid we used to play BB tag yeah we
did that supposed to like oh you can
only pump it twice
we would put cookie sheets on our front
and back we took like bacon sheets you
guys are in the pencils at least that
was you know what I mean nothing on our
face by the way just our chest and back
nothing to protect our face at all you
know Grandma I'm screaming about the
cookie sheets but my brother we had this
woodpecker that was living behind us not
not the Tom Segura woodpecker he he
killed a Woody Woodpecker this was just
a little guy but he's out there and my
brother just posted up in the window and
boom he hits his [__] woodpecker and
he's like I got it and we go out in this
Woodpecker's just this poor little
Woodpecker's just dead on the ground and
my brother picks it up that little heads
flopping and then all of a sudden it
pops up and goes
okay and then just because he was pissed
he takes his [__] hoodie string out
ties the [__] thing around this
Woodpecker's neck hangs it from a
[__] tree and I'm telling you we come
back the next day and it's gone and
there's little fox Prince under it and I
say this all the time somewhere there's
a fox out there going I'm telling you it
was hanging from a tree
can't make this [__] up Gary
just walk
it's Ronnie you're drunk No One Believes
that story sitting at some Fox bar
there's some fox out there that got a
free woodpecker the easy way bro
God
you know he walks by every tree still
it always looks like finding a 20. you
never know you're checking the Loose
Change in the phones he's somewhere in
Virginia tell him we got to get back to
Baltimore man they got woodpeckers
hanging from this man we got so many
animals we used to have we had
chameleons
two iguanas uh my brother was really
goddamn Galapagos he was big in the
snakes I'm not a snake that's trash
that's big any lizard bird or snakes
yeah we never have Birds we never I
always felt cruel having a bird I just
was like that thing can fly some people
do loose birds in the house which is
yeah
my favorite is when I see these in La
like my bird's missing I'm like my
bird's gone bro that bird just birded
what the [__] are you talking he just
remembered he was a bird he's nowhere
near here
um
but one it was uh God this is I'm in
high school I'm probably 15
um and it's my turn to cut the grass and
we had a riding mower and it was the
same Snapper that was Patrick Dempsey
wrote and Can't Buy Me Love shout out to
it okay great [__] movie great bag
catcher on the back like that was a big
deal we didn't have that Court McCown's
in that movie that's right it sure is
yeah he's in that and uh Teen Wolf
he's on the basketball team oh is he
yeah he sure is yeah
um a couple of hits right there kids
yeah do yourself a favor pick up Can't
Buy Me Love and all he's done is just
become better and better looking too
that's something dude crazy good looking
yeah I only met him once at New York
comedy club he's a great dude
um
but I see up so a neighbor lived a few
houses up and I'm in our backyard and
I'm looking at all the houses backyards
and I can see my brother and him they
got a trash can and they've got a broom
and they're hitting a pine tree and I'm
like oh there definitely is this they're
getting a snake and whatever time goes
by I don't think anything of it as I
come around
um I'm I'm in shape then it's summer my
shirt's off and I look up on our deck
and my brother's got like this six foot
black snake and I'm like don't do it
dude don't [__] throw it on me
so and I'm I'm listening to music I've
got the yellow Sony Walkman shout out to
it some Ozzy Osbourne just set in there
and you got to listen to every song or
fast forward and I'm going around and
the next time or two I come by and I
just feel something slap across the back
of my [__] neck and I look to my
right and there's this [__] snake
face right here and I said I grabbed
that [__] and I threw it on the
ground and I [__] put that blade down
he's like don't do it and I rode that
[__]
oh [__] chop that [__] up and dumped it
out of that bag and I said there's your
[__] snake my brother was crazy with
snakes I'm picking up on that my brother
we would go to the pet store you're what
we'd call normal events
the mulch
I did mulch up
[__] work for the Lucchesi family or
something like that [__] snakes he he
would go to the pet store and buy the
baby mice you know they they sell feeder
mice sure for people who have steaks
wait he was buying them without a snake
no no he would catch a wild snake and
then we'd go get your baby mice and I'm
just fascinated that's the craziest part
going to a pet store and getting the
snake is one thing catching one and
keeping it yeah that's an outdoor snake
and he puts it in a [__] aquarium
with lids on it and rocks on top of it
and [__] and then put the baby mice in
there and watch the snake do its thing
but this one time snakes won't eat
anything that's that's dead it's got to
be moving so this snake had hit this
[__] little mouse so much the damn
intestines are coming out of it and my
brother it was our little league money
and he was like I'm not wasting that
mouth say what the [__] are you gonna do
he ties fishing string to the tail he
dances
then he reaches in this is when I knew
he was crazy that snake bit him right on
the [__] hand dude I would have I
would have screamed freaked out I would
have gone to the [__] uh first aid
whatever this [__] just didn't
even look at his hand he just looked at
the [__] snake and he's like all
right you son of a [__] and I was like
you're not
Jesus then
my mom takes our younger brother to
um the pediatrician and we have to go
because we just have to [__] go and
we have a Volkswagen Beetle at the time
oh man he's talking about trash though
don't let me forget to tell you what we
did with that Beetle a beetle a
Volkswagen voted for insurance money at
that point we'll get to those but we're
sitting in the car we're like we're not
going in we're just gonna chill out here
in the car and my brother reaches in
this [__] jacket and pulls out a
goddamn snake a little I think they're
are they garter or gardeners I always
mess it up little garter snake and it's
just going around his hand I'm like what
the [__] where'd you get that he's like
I was in a bush when we walked outside
I'm like what you're [__] mental bro
you're [__] men there was that many
[__] snakes around yeah well
Maryland's full of copperheads and water
moccasins those are I didn't know that
oh yeah it's more like Low Land it's
water a lot of water when you're fishing
you'll see a water moccasin there
poisonous as [__] copperheads they're
big they're really poisonous too wait
what care about let's talk about mint
mobile mobile
yeah yeah how about that Ryan Reynolds
huh shout out to him good looking kid
nothing wrong with him gang inflation is
creeping up on everybody someone would
call it Bonkers everything has gone up
he got groceries you got gas she got
clothing except for who who hasn't it
mobile baby 15 a month get yourself all
set up and you know why why because they
don't do brick and mortar they pass the
savings right onto the consumer so you
choose yeah uh we've said it a bit I've
said it once I said a bajillion times we
love it my wife's been using it for
years uh it's easy peasy they sent it
right to your door set it in pop it in
boom you're all set and a price don't go
up it is what it is baby mobile 4 goes
the traditional cost of retail like you
said uh all plans come with unlimited
talk text and high speed data on the
nation's largest 5G Network that 5G baby
switching couldn't be easier to keep the
same phone your phone number and all of
your contacts the only thing that
changes is your bill and it goes down
okay to get your new Wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped right to your door for free
really go to mintmobile.com garbage
that's mintmobile.com garbage cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
midmobile.com garbage do it now back to
that gosh darn show
yeah LA's got all the rattlesnakes man
I've seen tons of those [__]
and they're dark and black I don't like
big and thick and they're right across
the trail when you're hiking I was I'm
an idiot I stepped off the trail to take
a piss because I'm just very worried
about any kids coming by and my dicks
out like I have a thing about that sure
so I'm behind this bush that's not a
thing that's the law which I respect
he called me old-fashioned
yeah
Jesus Christ now I might be a weirdo but
I don't like showing my dick to kids
but also I've been told if you're
pissing in public you can go on uh our
pedo register because your dick's out
you don't need that [__] I just don't
want to do that so I'm way in these
bushes and I see a hole and I'm like I'm
just gonna piss in this hole and I'm not
thinking at all and I'm pissing in this
hole and there's a whole [__] behind
me and this rattlesnake comes out and I
promise you it slithers right next to my
right foot
I'm terrified I can stay still and it
just goes right on [__] by and then I
just put my dick in my pants and left
out of that [__] thing I was like
good God that's the scariest part
because you have to remain calm in those
situations otherwise for sure he's gonna
get you and the other thing too is the
first thing you're going to want to do
is you're up on a hill or something
you're going to want to run to get help
and then then your blood starts pumping
hard so you're kind of and you're in
trouble you're in trouble I would have
freaked I would have [__] full-blown
panic yeah I'm not a fan of [__]
snakes I hated the reptile guy that
would come to school do you remember
[__] him yeah that guy would show up in
a van he'd be like here's a big tortoise
I'm like where are you getting these
yeah
these ain't at your house showing up in
a van
yeah it's just [__] in the back of
your van live in your mom's basement I
don't know where you're keeping these oh
I want to tell you what we did with this
Volkswagen
we're talking an old school VW Beetle
from the 70s this is the engine in the
back what color are we trunk in the
front exactly 100 it's red it's red but
it's older and it's Rusty from the all
the salt on the road over the years and
[__] and the the Yellow Pages remember
the Yellow Pages let your fingers do the
walking bad then
um they were doing a special
where they would paint your car whatever
color and then you had to put their
decals on your car and I think you did
it for six months to a year and then
after they pulled the decals off and you
have a free paint job so my parents
decide to do this and we get a Blue
Beetle now it was still so small we
called it the pants pocket this
[__] was small as [__] let's go
hopping up and there's five four or five
of us in there you know it's my parents
and three of us before they split and
then um
they peel the decals off you could
clearly see the [__] the outline so
our page is still red under us yeah it
was [__]
damn it was terrible yeah we pulled them
sicklers down there I love you guys okay
do you remember Hunter the show Hunter
of course okay Fred Dryer Fred Dryer
okay for the Chargers Dede was his girl
yeah and she drove this Dodge Chrysler
Laser it was called a Chrysler Laser big
deal back then it was a hot car was it a
convertible no look look I want you to
look this up if you don't mind because
in Baltimore at the time there was a
country station called 93 wpo that's all
right
country
yeah I remember that car they're giving
this car away okay WPOC the radio
station is giving this car away they're
93 WPOC and 93 people are going to get a
chance to win this brand new Chrysler
Laser okay damn that thing's sweet
though it was sweet that's like the
that's the epitome of an 80s car right
thank you and and remember what we have
so we're dying to get something like
this
so they do this at the Inner Harbor they
park the car at the Inner Harbor and
they roll window down and the contest I
think it might have been I don't know
how far the distance was it was 93
contestants maybe it was 93 feet I don't
know what it was but you had to [__]
throw football in this window and you
win a car okay my mother has three boys
who are very [__] athletic doesn't
ask us anything she's asking these
clowns where she works at this my mom
worked at this convenience store called
little George's
yeah
I don't do it there were like four of
them in Maryland you know I mean like
four not quite a change
[Laughter]
George's doing all right kids were going
to college but he was he wasn't a
[__] uh you're gonna have a lot of
little George's you got a little little
George he didn't have the ambition of a
wallet no exactly
and uh so she's asking clowns at her
work and she doesn't even practice at
all she does nothing
so it comes to the night we all go down
and
she might be like 85th she's in deep in
there and and if everyone misses they go
again okay right respect Everyone has
missed up to my mom and we're like here
we [__] go my mother's gonna laser
this Johnny Unitas right through that
goddamn window
and she [__] throws that ball
and that dead duck [__]
at about a quarter of the way there it
hits the dirt or concrete just skids off
to the side and we're like [__] this is
our that's that's a microcosm of our
whole [__] life right here right now
just too short and there's this [__]
guy who's been throwing the whole time
he's like three behind my mom he's been
throwing the whole time throwing only
one throwing the whole time with his
buddy and he [__] right in that
goddamn window lasers it so now everyone
before him's done and only anybody
behind him what does he do he's a pro he
goes right off to the side continues to
throw because I might have to throw
again holy [__] anyone that goddamn
Chrysler Laser nobody [__] Tom Brady
yeah stay on we were down there just for
heartbreak
got back in the Yellowstone got a [__]
got back in the Yellow Pages beetle with
a WPOC t-shirt and bumper sticker I got
some fresh gear dude
what were your cars
growing up yeah uh we had the the Woody
van in the early 90s that was when I
first remember like the maroon Woody van
uh and then she moved to a Ford Taurus I
believe yeah you couldn't tell our [__]
at that time that was that was it rolled
down Windows the whole nine then she she
moved to uh
she my brother convinced her to get a
used red Sebring convertible and she
bought it in February which didn't make
any questions we were riding around with
them [__] just Flex oh yeah yeah we
were like what the [__] is this she left
a top down a bunch [__] that thing up
that it provided yeah just a bunch of
mismatched cars used cars always you're
right she just got her first new car
probably about five years ago and it's
because she had the grandkids and my
brother and sister like you got to get a
better [__] car yeah you gotta get a
safe car safe reliable we we kicked it
off uh with a late 70s Ford Matador that
was my grandmother's
that I haven't heard that one in Forever
that we that we rolled in until maybe 85
86 and then we got a um a Pontiac 600 I
want to say it looked like the Grand
Prix but it was a little bigger still a
two-door doors were about 40 feet long
yeah
bike doors dude but I remember crying
when we pulled out of the uh the car
dealership because we were leaving the
Matador behind and I didn't understand
what was going on and I was you know my
grandmother's car all that kind of stuff
[__] killed me and then we had that
until
the 90s and then we had a real big
misstep on a GMC Jimmy that my dad
[__] hated and then the uh Nissan was
really popping so they started leasing
he bought a Nissan truck which was
awesome and my mom leased uh Maximus for
for a good run in the 90s and they were
[__] all right yeah but always always
a bad a bad lease didn't get anything
else just turn that [__] thing right
back in it's [__] ripping heaters in
it he kept it moving
they'd smoke it in a lease is a tough
they don't give a [__] what was your
first uh your first car with power
windows
great question Jesus
well I had um
my first car was a 1980 Toyota people
don't believe me when I say this but
I've had to prove it and I have it was
actually back then it was a Corolla
Tercel it was both then they broke them
up I remember the terms yeah they were
kind of like boxy a little bit Yeah they
had the hatchback and they have a
hatchback I remember they did but I had
I had the trunk but it also wasn't even
a it was a matte finish it wasn't even
it didn't you didn't even get a gloss
paint on that [__] it was dull
it was blue that was house paint dude
got that down at the Depot
no doubt and when I bought it my buddy
and I we drive it to Ocean City right
when we get it and I'm like what this
[__] a lot of gas smell coming in
here by the time we get to Ocean City I
pop the hood the fuel filter's busted
it's spitting wet gas into the car
everybody's like you ready to go out
we're like man we're tired we're sweet
we're like we're tired as [__] man
I'm ready to go to sleep man do we just
suck gas for two and a half [__]
hours
I'd save you on beers you know what I
mean
I had a 1990 Honda Civic with original
rims that's nice I drove that mother I
bought that from a junkyard that I
worked in which is where the the cars
come in stolen cars yeah but I worked
there and bought that and I drove that
[__] so to answer your question
that wasn't well into I drove that I had
that for until 300 000 miles so Jesus
Christ late in my 30s I I bought a from
an ex-girlfriend actually I bought a um
Jeep Cherokee and that was the first
that was all right our windows but it
wasn't because that one actually that
particular one ended up being the Lemon
Law and when I'm driving on the freeway
it would just go boo and it would shut
down talk about bad luck and then you
had lemon you had to stop on the freeway
put it in park and then turn it started
again and that started to get less and
less like the brakes will go out going
down the canyon roads and I would have
no power steering no brakes I would
float in the gas stations man I was like
this car is [__] deadly damn that
does make you being a dirt being a dirt
bag with a dirtbag car which I've
learned you really
learn how to think on your feet when
[__] goes the ins and outs you really
learn like all right I'm going downhill
there's a gas station I can clock it in
there my [__] transmission dropped
out of my Honda Civic one night and I
was driving to my job at UPS shout out
to UPS Baltimore primary one Joe Avenue
and Shout out you have the trashiest
shout out to the history of this show
and uh shout out to that Eiffel Tower
Kings Dominion hey don't forget about
stems Hardware everybody step Supply
y'all
um
and I worked probably from when I'm
living at my grandmother's place to
because I did live with my grandma for a
while and uh I'm driving to UPS and it's
probably I don't know two miles
and I only had first gear and I drove
that [__]
all the way to work I called my buddy
Shannon he owned the junkyard it was his
dad's he's the only guy like I don't
know how many people have a friend who
owns a rollback but he had a roll back
we had one growing up yeah and I'm like
can I were you the neighborhood toe as
well for everybody not really because he
was a bit of a prickly guy so nobody
wanted to ask him but we call our buddy
and be like I'd be like dude my my car
is a transmission shot it's sitting in
the lot at UPS will you come and [__]
tow it and just take it to my apartment
and then I'll [__] have AAA or
whatever tow it from there and he would
go do that [__] for us damn yeah it's
all right good time that is awesome
being in a roll yeah there's a certain
emotion of being in a [__] a roll off
truck where you're like it's fun because
you put you're like ah this is gonna
cost me 500 bucks yeah it'll cost me a
thousand dollars something yeah I had a
Honda Accord hatchback that every time I
every time I got gas I'd have to go in
there like a dirt bag and get a [__]
thing oil and [__] every every
everything man yeah and dude at the end
of this car I drove from uh my parents
house to my girlfriend's house in
Westchester uh PA drove back and it
sounded real weird I swear to God I
opened the hood and the engine or the
transmission was glowing red
dude it was that high it was probably
seconds from exploding and my dad came
out he was like what the [__] he was
like well you're done with this yeah you
get an appreciation you can't even work
on a car anymore you can't there's 20
the guys like there's 27 computers on
this car I'm like what the [__] I know I
remember I used to my car would overheat
all the time and I used to take this
like powder and put it in also I used to
say radiator yeah I still say ready yeah
I would say radiator people shamed me on
that one too what it's radiator but I
grew up with radiator those things those
those radiators over there yeah that's a
radiator we were taught you're gonna get
burned down radiator yeah the radiator
sounds like a surfer's nickname
I'm Kevin AKA well dude I had new kids
that were playing with it you don't go
by that now bro you better have a lot of
t-shirts coming out tomorrow bro
but I knew kids that would get sprayed
by them they'll bring their face you
don't open it up man you ever have a kid
show up to school in like third fourth
grade with [__] Birds
like what happened to you guys
I told you stay away from the radiator
Stephen I was laying there watching Fall
Guy and the radiator got me I sprayed
all over me [__] boiling out but
you learn [__] like these old mechanics
they lean on the radiator and then it
causes a hairline [__] fracture and
then next thing you know your shit's
overheating so I used to put this powder
in and this powder would Harden inside
gotcha and fill the crack and you get
maybe 10 000 miles and it's happening
again you just have to keep doing I
would put one time this mechanic put uh
this epoxy on it for me and I go is that
really gonna hold he's like this is
always like a this is what people always
say this [__] is a test like they put
this on the space shuttle you know it's
just nice which one the one that blew up
which there's two of them we've had
trouble with [__]
well yeah
as they told you that before 86 you'd be
like he [__] me yeah you would
you're right
yes I don't get the [__] out of here
yeah
um did you guys ever have kerosene
heaters growing up no no wow we got uh
we had two
in the car
I think we kept the beetle warm they
were so dangerous
that's a pipe bomb we had one that was
like that had the base and it was a
tower and you know my brothers and I
we'd always be [__] with we'd spit on
it all the time I'll put food on it but
then Grill snake I'd like grab your hand
I try to get you on there rookie oh God
damn it
it's so [__] hot and I look back at
it now we're in sixth grade and we've
got a [__] jug a blue jug of kerosene
in the house and we're children and
we've got the thing on it we're pouring
it in ourselves man I would never let
myself imagine your dog yeah that's
crazy [__] that I can't even believe
we're alive yeah we had a cold stove for
a long time we have one of those yeah we
used to get the coal wood sorry yeah
well we had coal and we'd get uh the
coal would get delivered and it would
get dumped into the [__] driveway me
my brother about to [__] shovel it
into a bin uh-uh I swear to God this was
in the 90s we had this thing when heat
exists dude in the 2004 but I'll tell
you what man that kept you real warm at
night we had a wood smells like a
bonfire it was it was a wood stove that
was that enclosed it was like the it was
like it sat on your fireplace mantle
yeah black one yeah black and it had
like a circle lid and you picked the
handle up and you just spun it this way
and you threw whatever and then you like
basically a dumpster yeah and you just
set a dumpster fire in the [__] house
yeah yeah did you go to school smelling
like wood a little oh smoke everything
like yeah my buddies that live down the
street uh shout out to Steve Pyle they
they had a regular fireplace that they
would use to heat the house and he would
show up smelling like [__] Franklin's
Barbecue
you've been camping again man
yeah we camp a lot yeah trout biting
again uh I remember my mom in the
morning wouldn't want to heat the house
so she would open this just turn the
stove on yeah open the stove just to
heat the kitchen
yeah just to get my license before a big
vocab test made it real cozy though
didn't make you not want to leave the
kitchen happy and [__] content in
there nice and warm uh uh all right we
gotta get to some [__] uh patreon
cues here gang as you know when you join
the patreon we will answer your Patriot
your garbage patreon questions on here
it's just the best way to do it patreon
gets the first crack at it because like
I said it's the greatest website of all
time uh this was from Garrett Canadian
homie here never have one red is it
garbage to test drive a truck to help a
buddy move a freezer
[Laughter]
that's brilliant is what that is that's
fantastic you can't [__] that truck up
though no what do you tell the sales guy
to make a quick stop
yeah I assume he's not with you
yeah they don't go with you now yeah at
least in L.A they don't wait really yeah
last time you leave your license with
them your driver's license with them and
then you go out on your own no for real
yeah yeah they don't care anymore sweet
yep my buddy's Dad I'll always I'll
never forget my buddy's dad uh owned a
body shop and he was selling a motor
like his motorcycle or something so this
guy showed up pulled his car in he was
like yeah man leave your car here and
you can go test drive like you'll test
drive the truck but just leave your car
here with the keys he's like yeah of
course man so the guy on the bike hops
on the bike drives away this is Vinnie
with the Skinny's dad drives away and uh
he's not whatever he's just like working
on a truck in the garage the guy who
pulled up in the car had a guy laying in
the back seat with a second set of keys
he hopped in drove the car off and they
made away with the bike in the car
completely gone hell yeah whoa he was
like I just got he's like I gotta
[__] respect the move because I never
even [__] thought of it that's
[__] crazy and just peeled out that
is that is smart uh all right let's see
here this is from page Dougherty anyone
your family ever smoked cigs in bed yeah
sure we smoked in the house but never in
bed I don't think you grew up a smoking
family only my grandma DeVito and
because we had this nice house that my
parents couldn't afford you know you
look back on and she lived with us for a
while I was like oh Grandma's kicking in
on this house you know but she had her
own dining room area in her own bedroom
and that's where she would smoke she was
Italian she would her diet was pretty
much Marlboro Lights peanuts and like
Diet Coke I'm living right now to be
honest pretty much that's it bro and
lottery tickets shout out to Nana DeVito
that's all right oh man uh all right
this one's from Bill anyone in your
family ever used the club on the
steering wheel of your car yeah myself
you oh man I still oh my no no no on my
Ig story anytime I see a club I throw it
up on the ice cubes club and yeah I got
a whole thing going I used to I mean I
had to be clubbing it like yeah it laid
right up underneath my the other day I
did one it was back to back clubs with
this car and this car I was like back to
back clubbed up y'all
um people I have a whole bit about it in
my album because what it always said was
it didn't say like I'm protecting this
car it was more of a message like this
is everything I [__] have you know
hey buddy I need this this is all I got
like a car payment's gonna put me under
right now okay [__] me up it's gonna
[__] me up so please move on and it's
just more of a deterrent like uh it's
gonna take me five minutes longer than
this one over here but yeah I clubbed it
up forever for years and years on that
Honda Civic
was it also like did you ever think it's
a weapon too if you ever get oh yeah two
pieces I always like the little over on
better yeah a little more I had I mean I
was good at it you know it's like a
Ninja Turtle
that'd be out of there
I also used one on my motorcycle I had a
motorcycle for a second I I've never
really enjoyed it I was never
comfortable on it I felt vulnerable and
weak on that [__] thing but I had
back one you know lock the back tire
Club thing and someone tried to come
steal it um the club club saved my car
so they ended up just busting the
windows out these [__] took the
carpet out of the hatchback so that's
how much they stole they wanted it all
they took the carpet off the back of my
seats like ripped it all out because of
course back then I had a box I had two
tens in the back shout out to the
subwoofer and an Alpine pull out uh
detachable face which is why I didn't
get that you know what I'm saying they
didn't get that
um but it saved the car from being
stolen and then the motorcycle someone
tried to steal but they couldn't get it
off so he just [__] dumped it over on
its side and [__] it up yeah did you
know you guys never clubbed it up never
that was already by the time I started
dry you know by the time I got my
license it was 2003 or whatever that was
already kind of kind of the door I guess
my brother had it I remember in his Jeep
he had a Jeep Cherokee he had that same
thing Car Alarm did you ever have the
Viper car alarm when you had the second
clicker like the yeah your own clicker
that guy showed up to a party he was
flashing yeah he wore his keys on his
belt yeah let you know you mean that's
right
you're right
uh all right let's see here uh this
one's from Romeo uh long time 10 homie
is a garbage to use a semi truck
casually one time my cousins their car
was dead so we took my uncle's semi
truck to church
casual casual rolling up the church
those without the trailer they look
sweet though think without the trailer
remember the flat one the flat-faced
ones remembering and Smokey and the
Bandit they would race them they would
have tractor races but it was just a
tractor on that phone yeah it was all
right no I think that's a boss movie
yeah but I'm trash
it's great on a curve with it can you do
that is that legal can I just get a
tractor trailer as long as the plates
are yeah you can't there was this um I
can't put a regular set of tags on it no
I got you you gotta have a CDL for that
[__] but if I got a CD I could
roll around I was supposed to have CDO
for that [__]
you got to pass Division and piss tests
that's commercial bro it's conversion we
ain't talking Recreation
I guess that ain't happening then my
eyesight stinks and I ain't making it
just set that as your goal you should do
it bro go get your CD oh man
what are you talking about it's a great
goal yeah double clutch and then go
drive an 18-wheeler for your fans oh God
I tune in to watch the whole process oh
baby we gotta wrap it up though gang
this has been [__] fantastic ah
ladies and gentlemen Mr Ryan sickler has
an amazing special out right now called
Lefty son it's on his YouTube page you
have to check it out of course the host
of the Honeydew podcast thank you guys
buddy we can't thank you enough we love
you love you anything you want the folks
out there to know hit them uh yeah
subscribe to honeydew uh watch my
special this is something I put as a
labor of love myself like we say these
free podcasts and specials are
definitely not free to bring to y'all
and um everything's on Ryan sickler.com
my tour dates all of it's there go check
it out buddy we love you we love it
so much congratulations on everything
you're [__] killing it we're so happy
for you thank you Kippy what do you got
for him guys we're all over the road
tickets are on sale we're adding second
shows in some places get those tickets
before they're gone thanks for
everything we love you gang we love you
we'll see you next week peace